the site of the exhausted but defined
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
filming himself in the streets of kiev
as russians shelled the city captured
the world's imagination rarely is a
world leader seen recording selfies from
a city under attack
already
ukrainian people are a true inspiration
he's a very brave brave man what this
dude is doing
it is incredibly moving russian forces
far outnumbered ukraine's army and
zalenski's prolific online and social
media messaging in the first crucial
days of the invasion helped galvanize
widespread support for ukraine this is
how he did it
until russia invaded ukraine vladimir
zelinski was to most people simply a
supporting character in the first
impeachment of former u.s president
donald trump in 2019. that episode
focused on trump's request to zelensky
to look into then-democratic
presidential candidate joe biden and his
son hunter during a conversation about
releasing u.s military aid to ukraine
zielinski took on a leading role when he
became the face of ukraine's resistance
against russian president vladimir
putin's forces there's something about
the personal reportage that makes it
powerful you know the kind of
sort of cinema verite kind of approach
andrew chadwick is a political scientist
based in the uk who studies the role of
the internet and new media in political
communications he was very effective at
communicating to the public that are in
the nations that he needed to get on
side partly because he knew that it was
important to reach them so that they
would put pressure on their governments
the 44 year old spoke regularly with
western leaders imploring them to step
up their actions against putin and grant
the country admission to nato
zolensky was particularly effective i
think in cutting through in a way that
often is difficult to do
in a
military conflict using direct video
communication that he knew was likely to
be circulated on social media there's a
certain emotionality involved in his
communication as well
one of the most striking images that
came out of the pre-war period when
putin met with emmanuel macron the
french leader was this huge table that
they sat at either end of in one of
zelensky's talks he actually drew
attention to the distance that putin had
established and kind of taunted him for
it
then
it's interesting to consider the
cultural uh power of somebody like
zelensky i mean he started out you know
in show business as a comedian as an
actor as a stage performer and so he
understands quite readily i think in a
way that most ordinary people don't what
it takes to really cut through
with with messaging
before he was elected president in 2019
zielenski was best known for his
television role as an ordinary school
teacher accidentally catapulted into
power
the show servant of the people ran for
four years making him a household name
in ukraine clips from zalenski's past as
an entertainer including an appearance
on ukraine's version of dancing with the
stars were widely shared online after
war broke out
where
these videos have gone viral
particularly on twitter
i can see that that people think that
they want to do their bit by sort of
sharing these to boost the cultural
profile of zelensky but of course
whether or not that makes much
difference at the ground level when it
comes to the brutal reality of the
conflict is a different matter entirely
zolensky's direct appeals to western
leaders and his regular online video
addresses helped shape the response to
russia's invasion harsher economic
sanctions against russia followed a call
with allies in which zolensky told those
present it might be the last time they
saw him alive
according to several diplomats
and pro-ukraine rallies took place in
cities across the globe
i i think the whole world has as uh
recognized that the power of one person
president zielinski to motivate a a
nation uh has been demonstrated in a way
we will not forget i think what's
happened is that digital media and
social media have changed the game of
warfare and wartime communications
and they've democratized it and that
makes
these kinds of conflicts very different
from the traditional
understanding of conflicts that we
inherited from the 20th century and
zielenski recognized that
which
which is
you